monsieur le garde des sceaux chers
collègues nous avons le plaisir monsieur
le ministre de vous accueillir
aujourd'hui pour la première fois sous
cette législature pour nous présenter
votre feuille de route la vôtre est
particulièrement chargée car en ce début
de législature va correspondre à la mise
en œuvre des préconisations des états
généraux de la justice qui vont être au
cœur des chantiers menés par votre
ministère dans les prochaines années le
comité des états généraux de la Justice
a travaillé de façon intense entre
octobre 2021 et avril 2022 et a rendu un
rapport particulièrement complet que je
vous invite tous à consulter puisqu'il
est disponible et public et sur cette
base vous avez bien naturellement
organisé une large concertation avant de
prendre position sur les suites à donner
aux préconisations des Etats généraux de
la justice ainsi que sur leur calendrier
c'est pour quoi nous avons souhaité
attendre la fin des consultations avant
de vous entendre sur leur mise en oeuvre
et votre feuille de route elle ne se
résume pas aux Etats généraux de la
justice le suivi des réformes déjà
menées primordial c'est d'ailleurs pour
cette raison que la commission des lois
à d'ores et déjà créer une mission
d'information qui va vous intéresser au
premier chef puisqu'il s'agit d'évaluer
la mise en œuvre du code de justice
pénale des mineurs cette mission a été
confiée à nos collègues Jean Tellier et
à madame Cécile tomayer
monsieur le ministre vous présenterez un
peu plus tard devant notre commission à
un budget exceptionnel en hausse de 8%
pour la troisième année consécutive en
faisant mes mots je peux tout dire je
peux tout même dire que c'est du jamais
vu et ça invite plusieurs questions
pouvez-vous d'abord dresser un bilan des
affectations des crédits budgétaires de
ces dernières années leur incidence sur
les juridictions comme dans
l'administration quel service on en
bénéficier quelles en sont en ont été
les effets et avec quelle traduction
notamment sur l'écoulement des stocks
d'affaires qui avaient été très
importants en raison d'abord de
plusieurs perturbations avec des grèves
notamment des avocats ou avec encore les
interruptions sur le covid
les États-Unis de la justice proposait
d'ailleurs la mise en oeuvre d'un
référentiel de moyens d'excès sur la
charge de travail des juridictions vous
pouvez cette mesure est en réglementaire
pouvez-vous nous indiquer si vous
envisagez la mettre en oeuvre et dans
quel délai je souhaite aussi revenir sur
des faits d'actualité de cet été
beaucoup a été dit et écrit sur nos
prisons beaucoup de choses étranges de
réalité déformées ou de vérité spéculer
pour que ces contre-vérités
d'intoxiquent pas l'Assemblée nationale
j'ai souhaité diffuser à mes collègues
l'excellent rapport de la commission
d'enquête Benassaya Abadie sur les
prétendus dysfonctionnement de
l'administration pénitentiaire nous
députés de la commission des lois nous
exercerons aussi notre droit de visite
en prison individuellement et
collectivement lors d'une visite que
j'annonce à Fresnes le 14 octobre
prochain avant nous visionner la
Contrôleur général des lieux de
privation de liberté je souhaiterais
qu'une fois s'y connaître à notre
commission l'état d'avancement du plan
de construction des 15000 places de
prison je voudrais que vous l'éclairiez
sur les mesures de réinsertion mise en
oeuvre par les directions la direction
de l'administration pénitentiaire et les
services pénitentiaires d'insertion et
probation sur le travail avec les élus
locaux les entreprises les associations
pour préparer la sortie et lutter contre
la récidive
pas davantage des débats je sais que les
questions sont nombreuses j'ai déjà 31
inscrits je rappelle donc il s'agit
d'une audition et que le format est de 2
minutes pour toutes les questions
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
pour une intervention de
monsieur le président
de la commission des lois de l'Assemblée
nationale
cher Sacha
mesdames messieurs les membres de la
commission des lois je suis
particulièrement heureux
de revenir devant votre commission alors
que s'ouvrira dans quelques jours la
première session ordinaire de cette
nouvelle législature
je vais d'abord vous féliciter
toutes et tous de manière républicaine
pour vos élections respectives
à tous égards les enjeux qui nous font
face sont immenses
alors que le pays connaît une situation
inédite depuis un demi-siècle en termes
géopolitique et économique ce contexte
nous impose de travailler différemment
et faire en sorte que les réformes
indispensables se fassent dans le plus
large consensus
en matière de justice c'est ce que nous
avons fait sous l'impulsion du Président
de la République et à la demande des
deux plus hauts magistrats de ce pays
avec l'exercice démocratique inédit des
étages généraux de la justice nous
parlons ici de près d'un million de
contributions citoyennes et de plusieurs
dizaines de réunions avec nos
concitoyens partout sur le territoire
pour discuter ensemble de la justice que
nous appelons de nos vœux
alors que le rapport de très grande
qualité
issue de ces états généraux de la
justice a été remis au Président de la
République par le président sauvé en
juillet dernier je suis en train de
conclure la dernière phase de
concertation de tous les acteurs du
monde judiciaire sur la base des
conclusions de ce rapport et des annexes
comme je l'ai annoncé je présenterai
dans les semaines qui viennent un plan
d'action détaillé
pour réformer
améliorer le service public de la
justice avec un impératif rendre plus
rapide plus efficace plus proche de nous
concitoyens notre institution judiciaire
ce plan d'action que je viendrai vous
présenter le moment venu se déclinera à
travers tous les leviers dont nous
disposons l'objectif sera d'aller vite
c'est pourquoi tout ce qui pourrait être
fait par voie réglementaire le serein et
ce dans les plus brefs délais je pense
par exemple à la matière civile ou
encore à l'organisation propre du
ministère mais il nous faut être lucide
et ce gouvernement avec sa majorité
parlementaire l'ont été depuis
maintenant quelques années la justice
manque de moyens
oui nous avons augmenté de plus de 40%
le budget depuis 5 ans oui nous avons
recruté près de 700 magistrats de 850
greffiers là où les précédentes
majorités ont recruté quelques dizaines
quand elles n'ont supprimé pas
oui nous avons recruté plus de 2000
juristes assistants renfort de greffe
assistant de justice autrement qualifiés
de sucre rapide pour venir épauler les
magistrats et greffiers qui s'engagent
au quotidien dans leur mission pour
faire fonctionner le service public de
la justice partout sur notre territoire
je le dirai
et je le répéterai inlassablement à ceux
qui essaient de faire croire que plus
est égal à moins car on ne résout pas 20
ou 30 ans d'abandon politique humain
budgétaire en un claquement de doigts
oui le gouvernement est particulièrement
lucide sur ce constat c'est pourquoi
nous allons poursuivre cet effort ce
matin j'ai présenté à la presse et aux
organisations syndicales à toutes les
organisations syndicales un projet de
budget 2023 qui pour la troisième fois
consécutive sera en hausse de plus de 8%
ça fait deux ans que je viens devant
cette commission vous dire que ces
hausses sont historiques cette année
encore je ne Déroche pas à la règle
c'est un triplet historique qui peut à
peu nous laisse entrevoir
l'horizon d'une justice de qualité que
tous les acteurs du monde judiciaire
mais surtout les justiciables appellent
de leurs vœux
si je peux pas décliner mon plan
d'action aujourd'hui devant vous alors
que l'ultime phase de consultation n'est
pas terminée je peux d'ores et déjà vous
annoncer
qu'une première recommandation et non
des moindres du rapport sauvé sera suivi
car j'y ai mis si j'ose dire tout mon
poids nous embaucherons au moins
1500 magistrats et 1500 greffiers sur le
quinquennat il s'agit là du plus grand
plan d'embauche de toute l'histoire les
services judiciaires
les ambitions fixées par le Président de
la République et la première ministre
l'imposait c'est désormais acté avec
l'aide de l'appui précieux de mes
collègues Bruno Le Maire et Gabriel
Attal qui ont compris dans un contexte
de contrainte économique que la justice
devait demeurer une priorité
c'est la plus qu'un symbole c'est la
preuve indiscutable
qui démontre la place primordiale
qu'occupe la justice au sein de l'État
et aux yeux de cette majorité monsieur
le Président je crois que nous avons
fixé l'audition budgétaire devant votre
commission au 25 octobre prochain c'est
pourquoi je ne rentrais je ne rentrerai
pas plus en détail sur la question des
crédits pour l'année 2023 mais je ne
répondrai naturellement à toutes les
questions voudraient bien me poser après
le volet réglementaire budgétaire et
organisationsnel les arbitrages
issus des concertations en cours
prendront forme et corps à travers une
ambitieuse loi de programmation pour la
justice sur la période 2022-2027
fidèle à la démarche de co-construction
qui est la mienne le Parlement sera très
étroitement consulté en amont des débats
et aura bien sûr toute la place qui lui
revient au moment de l'examen de ce
texte
ces réformes viseront à nous accorder
sur l'ampleur des réformes législatives
de la justice que nous aurons apporté
qu'elle soit programmatique ordinaire
organique ou même constitutionnel
si la loi de programmation permettra
d'inscrire dans le marbre les
recrutements massifs à venir de
magistrats de greffier mais aussi de
personnels pénitentiaires elle aura
également vocation à transposer dans la
loi et de manière concise les
principales propositions
qui auront fait pour la plupart déjà
consensus
pour répondre à votre question ce
président la loi de programmation
devrait être présenté devant le
Parlement début 2023 afin notamment de
permettre les discussions évoquées
plutôt dans mon propos vous l'avez
compris ma priorité est de poursuivre le
renforcement sans précédent de notre
justice qui est à l'oeuvre déjà depuis
plusieurs années mais je veux aussi vous
déclinez ainsi que je les fais au
procureur dans ma dernière circulaire de
politique générale les priorités de ma
politique pénale
ma priorité est claire restaurer le
droit à vivre dans la tranquillité pour
nos concitoyens
j'ai ainsi rappelé ma volonté d'avoir
une justice pénale plus protectrice face
aux attaques inacceptables et à la
délinquance du quotidien et pour cela
c'est simple j'ai demandé au parquet en
priorité de choses fermeté dans la
réponse pénale et célérité des
poursuites à cela s'ajoute l'intangible
individualisation des peines et leur
exécution rapide sans oublier un
accompagnement renforcé des victimes de
tout cela j'en suis sûr nous reparlerons
dans quelques instants
ces objectifs clairs doivent se
retrouver dans le traitement pénal de
toutes les infractions du quotidien que
sont par exemple les rodéons dans les
condamnations ont été multipliées par 15
depuis 2018 les agressions intolérables
qu'elles soient racistes
antisémites
homophobe les atteintes à nos élus les
forces de l'ordre qui constituent les
attaques contre la République ou encore
les squats qui sont insupportables car
ils nourrissent le sentiment d'impunité
et contre lesquels je veux renforcer
l'arsenal juridique je sais d'ailleurs
certains d'entre vous très engagés sur
la question chère Philippe
puisque je suis devant les
parlementaires
je veux aussi vous affirmer ma
détermination à poursuivre la mise en
oeuvre de la justice de proximité en
développant une justice partenariale
avec tous les acteurs locaux
dont les FSI et les élus dans le cadre
notamment des groupes locaux de
traitement de la délinquance il s'agit
là d'adapter au mieux la réponse pénale
en réalité du terrain car tous
sont dans la même barque que
républicaine
j'ai également tenu un réaffirmer la
persistance à haute intensité de notre
lutte contre le terrorisme en ne
sous-estimant pas les signaux faibles
qui constituent les symptômes d'une
radicalisation à l'oeuvre tel que
l'apologie du terrorisme ou la haine en
ligne qui dispose désormais de son
propre parquet spécialisé j'ai donc
demandé au procureur de saisir
pleinement les nouveaux outils
juridiques offerts par la loi
réaffirmant les principes de la
République enfin
la circulaire de politique pénale
générale du 20 septembre dernier
souligne avec force l'importance d'agir
contre la destruction de l'environnement
et de la biodiversité
ainsi j'ai demandé au parquet de se
saisir de ces nouveaux outils que sont
les pôles judiciaires régionaux de
l'environnement où les conventions
judiciaires d'intérêt public
environnemental mais aussi par exemple
de requérir les plus sévères sanctions
vis-à-vis des auteurs d'incendie
prémédités et volontaires qui détruisent
nos forêts nous le savons à la sortie de
cet été qui a ravagé nos paysages et
ravagé nos forêts et notre biodiversité
pour conclure
la présentation de la feuille de route
pénale je veux m'attarder plus
longuement sur deux de mes principales
priorités d'abord
la lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes
c'est l'affaire de tous
magistrat
force de l'ordre
mais aussi collègues de bureau
voisins nous avons tous je dis bientôt
tous un rôle à jouer pour faire remonter
les cas de violence car trop souvent la
justice n'a pas été prévenue à temps
cette libération de la parole doit se
poursuivre depuis le Grenelle j'ai tenu
à ce que la justice se mobilise comme
jamais auparavant
pour lutter
contre ce fléau constitue les violences
faites aux femmes
sous notre impulsion est grâce à
l'engagement des magistrats des
greffiers des forces de l'ordre des
associations de les oublions pas nous
avons permis la mise en place de
dispositifs efficaces avec
4318 téléphones graves d'Angers
aujourd'hui déployés contre seulement
300 en 2019
860 bracelets anti-rapprochement
actuellement actif et
5921 demande d'ordonnance de protection
adressée aux juridictions en 2021 contre
3131 demandes en 2017 je veux ici
saluer vos collègues Guillaume Vittet et
Aurélien Pradier je le dis nous devons
poursuivre nos efforts sans relâche
bien sûr chaque féminicide est un
féminicide de trop chaque violence
quelle qu'elle soit est une violence de
trop mais je veux le rappeler devant
cette commission
qui a tente vrai pour construire notre
État de droit l'enceinte judiciaire et
le seul endroit en démocratie où se rend
la justice
ne se rend pas dans des Sénats
politiques
des comités de déontologie adopte
tous ces monstres en dehors du cadre
légal sont d'ailleurs en train de
dévorer cela même qui les ont créés dans
la violation de nos principes juridiques
les plus fondamentaux je le dis
clairement cela doit impérativement
cesser parce que la justice doit
poursuivre sa transformation
j'ai par ailleurs annoncé la
prolongation pour une durée de trois ans
des 105 chargés de mission de catégories
a affecté dans les juridictions et
spécifiquement dédié à la lutte contre
les violences conjugales
pour mieux accueillir la parole des
femmes et traiter les violences
insupportables qu'elles subissent la
première ministre vient d'annoncer une
mission parlementaire qui aura la charge
d'évaluer ces dispositifs afin de
garantir une action judiciaire
spécialisée dans tous les territoires de
la République
je veux ensuite
vous parlez d'une autre de mes priorités
absolues la lutte contre les violences
faites aux mineurs
l'objectif au moins est de repérer le
plus tôt possible les situations de
danger et d'agir avec la plus grande
efficacité dans l'intérêt supérieur de
nos enfants
protéger les enfants c'est aussi
renforcer comme nous le faisons leur
accompagnement quand ils sont victimes
en améliorant leur prise en charge tout
au long du processus pénal en lien avec
les unités d'accueil pédiatrique enfance
en danger et les associations d'aide aux
victimes je vous confirme mon intention
de permettre désormais le retrait de
principe de l'autorité parentale en cas
de condamnation d'un parent pour
violence sexuelle sur son enfant le juge
ne pourra pas y déroger sauf motivation
spéciale
enfin
Mesdames et Messieurs les parlementaires
aucune politique pénale ne pourra
efficacement prospérer sans la
simplification de la procédure pénale
réclamée par tous les acteurs du monde
judiciaire
le président de la République s'y est
engagé et j'aurais donc vocation à vous
proposer une méthode consensuelle et une
feuille de route claire pour qu'ensemble
si vous en êtes d'accord nous puissions
mener ce chantier législatif colossal
cette réforme fait l'objet d'un large
consensus des forces de l'ordre au
magistrat en passant par les avocats
comme en témoigne les conclusions du
bobo de la sécurité menés par mon
collègue Gérald Darmanin mais également
celle des états généraux de la justice
comme vous le savez
une politique pénale
ne peut exister sans politique
pénitentiaire volontariste rappelons-le
la prison à trois objectifs
sanctionner le délinquant
protéger la société des individus
dangereux mais aussi
réinsérer les condamnés afin qu'il ne
récidive pas pour punir le délinquant et
protéger nos concitoyens il est
indispensable que nous ayons
suffisamment de place de prison il en va
également de la qualité des conditions
de travail du personnel pénitentiaire
que l'on oublie trop souvent troisième
force de sécurité intérieure du pays et
un travail remarquable dans un contexte
parfois très difficile qu'ils
accomplissent au quotidien je veux ici
et à cet instant le rendre un hommage
particulièrement appuyé il en va
également bien sûr
de la dignité des conditions de
détention dans notre pays depuis la fin
du mois d'août un certain nombre d'entre
vous ont eu une prise de conscience et
ce sont des placées en nombre dans nos
établissements pénitentiaires je salue
cet exercice démocratique indispensable
car il vous a permis de constater par
vous-même que contrairemente aux
affirmations de certains sur certaines
chaînes d'informations continuent la
prison n'est pas le Club Med
c'est d'ailleurs tout le problème des
images qui ont été diffusées concernant
la prison de Fresnes
elle laissait à croire aux honnêtes gens
que la prison était un parc d'attraction
et ces images laissaient courir l'idée
parmi notre jeunesse qu'elle est en
prison au final c'était pas bien grave
lol
si la prison est grave la prison doit
dissuader
mais si elle doit dissuader
ça n'est pas par l'insalubrité ou
l'indignité des conditions de détention
je veux ici rendre hommage au travail de
votre collègue Caroline Abadie sur ce
sujet précis
pourtant la France a été condamné de
nombreuses reprises c'est pour toutes
ces raisons
une réponse pénale assurée de bonnes
conditions de travail pour les agents
pénitentiaires et des conditions de
détention dignes sont absolument
nécessaires et c'est pour toutes ces
raisons que nous avons lancé le plus
grand plan immobilier pénitentiaire
Depuis 40 ans les chantiers poussent
partout en France
si vous me permettez l'expression
il pousse comme des champignons et j'ai
d'ailleurs eu l'occasion d'en visiter un
certain nombre cet été dans certaines de
vos circonscriptions nous attendrons
nous atteindrons les 15000 places
supplémentaires d'ici la fin 2027
conformément aux engagements du
Président de la République
sur le volet insertion je le répète
il n'est pas possible de concevoir la
prison sans le volet réinsertion il est
absolument
indissociable du volet répressif
les événements de Fresnes nous ont
permis de préciser par la circulaire du
21 septembre le cadre applicable à ses
activités l'objectif est de renforcer
leur contrôle tout en préservant bien
sûr une souplesse au niveau local afin
de ne pas brider les initiatives des
chefs d'établissement pertinents dans
leur écrasante majorité le programme
immobilier se caractérise par la
création de 2000 places au sein de SAS
structure d'accompagnement vers la
sortie
nous savons que les sorties sèches
génèrent davantage de récidive que les
sorties accompagnées c'est ça accueille
des condamnés à des peines de moins de 2
ans fin de peine et l'expérimentation
d'établissement est tournée vers le
travail
ces établissements sont dénommés insert
l’une des priorités de mon action est
enfin de ramener le travail en détention
qui me soit permis de dire que le
contrat du détenu travailleur
a fait moins de presse
que le kart à Fresnes
le kart à Fresnes davantage intéressant
que le contrat du détenu travailleur
l'une des priorités de mon action
est de ramener le travail en détention
depuis le début des années 2000 l'offre
de travail en détention a été divisé par
deux
ma mobilisation sur ce sujet porte ses
fruits malgré deux années de crise
sanitaire
2021 est marquée par une hausse de 3
points du travail pénitentiaire
par rapport à 2018 31% de la population
des tenues aura travaillé en détention
l'offre de travail en production a
augmenté ces dernières années puisque
près de 90 nouvelles entreprises se sont
implantées en détention entre 2019 et
2022 je l'ai dit souvent le sens du
travail le sens de l'effort ne sont pas
des sens interdits en prison ainsi en
janvier 2023
entrera en vigueur la suppression des
remises de peine automatique et leurs
conditionnement à l'effort pour là
encore mettre l'action sur la
réinsertion
alors que l'objectif poursuivi est de
redonner du sens à la peine
certaines peines sont déjà pleines de
sens je pense en particulier au travail
d'intérêt général qui est au cœur de la
justice de proximité avec un mot d'ordre
tu casses tu répares tu salis tu
nettoies tu indemnises avec la création
de la tige je veux ici rendre hommage à
ma prédécesseur ainsi qu'à Didier Paris
nous avons substantiellement renforcé
l'offre de tiges et leur accessibilité à
tous les acteurs judiciaires avocats
magistrats via la plateforme tige 360 je
prendrai d'ici la fin de l'année une
circulaire pour poursuivre ce mouvement
afin que les juridictions se saisissent
davantage de cet outil pénal formidable
à chaque fois bien sûr je le précise à
chaque fois que possible si le travail
d'accompagnement est important pour les
délinquants adultes il est absolument
primordial chez les mineurs qui sont des
adultes et des citoyens en devenir ma
priorité en la matière et de réduire
drastiquement les délais de jugement des
mineurs délinquants
la délinquance des mineurs était
insuffisamment traitée et ce alors même
que sa violence s'accroît
il était donc indispensable d'accélérer
et de renforcer la réponse judiciaire en
la matière ces choses faites
grâce à l'œuvre commune du code de
justice pénale des mineurs
alors que nous fêterons dans quelques
jours les 1 an de son entrée en vigueur
je peux d'ores et déjà vous indiquer que
les délais ont été massivement réduits
passant parfois du double au simple sans
mauvais jeu de mots afin de développer
tous les outils
qui remettent les mineurs délinquants
dans le droit chemin j'aurai à cœur de
mettre en œuvre l'engagement du
président de la République
crée un partenariat adapté entre le
ministère des armées
et la protection judiciaire de la
jeunesse
ce partenariat se fonde pas sur de
vieilles lunes mais sur une
expérimentation concrète menée l'année
passée avec un taux de réussite proche
de 80%, 8 jeunes sur 10 tirés d'affaires
dans cette même logique nous
poursuivrons le grand plan de
construction de champs éducatif fermé
à mes yeux outils efficace pour éviter
la récidive des mineurs délinquants et
là encore les remettre dans le droit
chemin et aujourd'hui on compte 22 Sept
construits ou dont les opérations ont
été lancées la lutte contre la
délinquance des mineurs méritent que
l'on se donne tous les moyens et qu'on
use de tous les outils indispensables
enfin ma mission est pas des moindres va
également consister à poursuivre le
rapprochement entre la justice civile et
nos concitoyens
on oublie souvent
mais le plus fréquemment le seul contact
qu'aura le citoyen avec la justice au
cours de sa vie sur un contact avec la
justice civile une procédure de divorce
un litige avec son propriétaire son
locataire une demande de mis sous
tutelle ou même un différent entre deux
commerçants bref
la vie quotidienne et que nous disent
les usagers de justice à travers les
conclusions des États généraux
ils nous disent de choses
apparemment contradictoires que la
justice est trop lente
mais quand même temps elle n'a pas le
temps de les écouter
c'est pour répondre à cette double
injonction que je souhaite dans le cadre
de mon futur plan d'action donner à la
justice civile la place qu'elle mérite
une place de choix
c'est-à-dire d'abord lancer à l'échelle
nationale une politique ambitieuse de
l'amiable
une décision de justice co-construite
est une décision mieux acceptée dans ce
cadre le juge doit pouvoir proposer et
inciter les parties à recourir à un
médiateur ou un conciliateur l'offre de
ces modes amiable doit également
s'étoffer et s'adapter à la nature du
litige comme à la personnalité des
parties je vous annonce que l'obtention
d'un accord même partiel dans un cadre
amiable sera valorisé y compris
financièrement pour les avocats qui
interviendront au titre de l'aide
juridictionnelle parallèlement à cela il
faut simplifier le parcours
juridictionnel de justiciable qui
ressemble bien souvent un parcours du
combattant
beaucoup a déjà été fait notamment avec
la création du service d'accueil unique
de justiciable et les 2000 points
justice mais je veux aller plus loin en
facilitant la saisine du juge en
organisant la juridiction en pôles
facilement
identifiable et pourquoi pas en mettant
à portée de smartphones les outils pour
accompagner le justiciable dans ses
démarches la justice ne doit plus rester
en marge de la transition numérique du
service public enfin il s'agit de
poursuivre sans relâche nos efforts de
résorption des stocks
Mesdames et Messieurs les stocks en
matière civile on diminué de 28% au
niveau national cette absolument
considérable
pour suivre cet effort permis par les
recrutements de la justice de proximité
et l'engagement des magistrats et des
greffiers passera par un plan d'embauche
massif comme indiqué au début de mon
propos mais également par la mise en
place d'une équipe pérenne autour du
magistrat
enfin bien sûr dans le contexte
économique qui s'assombrit
je n'oublie pas la justice économique
qui est un de nos joyaux et souhaite
m'inspirer des conclusions du rapport
sauvé pour la renforcer notamment en ce
qui concerne l'expérimentation d'un
tribunal des affaires économiques il
nous faudra également favoriser la
création d'une filière de juge civiliste
compétent en matière économique
et encourager les échanges entre
magistrats de carrière et jugent
consulaire
renforcé dans ces missions davantage
ouvertes sur le monde judiciaire
économique notre justice consulaire sera
aux avant-postes pour promouvoir notre
droit français et assurer son
rayonnement au-delà des frontières pour
conclure je souhaite aborder l'un des
sujets si ce n'est le sujet majeur pour
l'avenir du ministère de la Justice
celui de sa transformation numérique
si de nombreux chantiers ont été menés à
bien depuis 5 ans il reste cependant
beaucoup pas faire ainsi tous les agents
du ministère le nécessitant ont par
exemple été doté d'un ordinateur
portable au-delà de la stratégie
numérique à long terme un travail
important sur la capacité des réseaux va
permettre en fin d'année une
augmentation très nette du débit cette
augmentation facilitera la capacité des
juridictions à traiter le contentieux et
limitera le risque de crash réseau de
même
dans la suite des états généraux de la
justice je vous annonce qu'une centaine
de contractuels spécifiquement formés
sera déployée dans les juridictions afin
d'assister les tribunaux au quotidien en
matière numérique et informatiques il
est prévu à terme pour chaque
juridiction au moins un technicien ou un
référent informatique présent sur site
voilà donc Madame et messieurs mesdames
et messieurs les députés de manière
presque complète sans doute trop longue
les grands axes de ce que vous me
permettez d'appeler la saison 2 que j'ai
eu l'honneur de vous présenter cet
après-midi je me tiens bien évidemment à
votre disposition pour répondre à toutes
les questions que vous voudrez bien me
poser
merci Monsieur le Ministre elles sont
nombreuses nombreuses que j'ai déjà 37
inscrits pour vous interroger alors on
va commencer par Monsieur Didier Paris
pour le groupe Renaissance merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre en réalité ma question mes
observations portées essentiellement sur
sur des indications que vous nous avez
déjà largement donné donc je vais
synthétiser premier élément il est clair
et vous l'avez dit que la situation de
la justice en France qui est pour moi
mauvaise et très probablement le
résultat décennie de politique publique
défaillante c'est d'ailleurs très
clairement relevé dans le rapport Sauvé
a pour sauver qui était demandé par le
Président de la République pour tenter
et on peut le on peut le comprendre de
réhabiliter une service public et de
restaurer ce qui est fondamental le
Pacte civique entre la nation et la
justice
sinon cet esprit que vous avez vous-même
travaillé que vous avez les rapporteurs
le disent eux-mêmes donnaient un mandat
de liberté à la commission sauvée y
compris d'ailleurs à ses travailleurs
comme directeur de cabinet à vos côtés
qui a été extrêmement actif dans cette
dans cette opération monsieur Congo
Excel les propositions faites sont
nombreuses vous les avez évoquées pour
une bonne partie d'entre elles vous en
avez tiré les conséquences en tout cas
pour une partie d'entre elles notamment
la clarification du rôle de la justice
par rapport aux autres institutions qui
a un problème fondamental et jamais bien
réglé le renforcement de ma première
instance et le retour le retour
finalement à la collégialité et le rôle
de nos cours d'appels que totalement
débordés dans contexte actuel une
gestion des ressources humaines c'est le
travail autour du juge mais pas que
gestion fondamentale une totale refonte
de la stratégie numérique vous l'avez
évoquée la réorganisation du pilotage
des concentrés du ministère on le voit
le chantier gigantesque en même parler
des des difficultés
sectorielles que vous avez évoqué civil
économique commerciale et ainsi de suite
vous entamez ce dernier round de
concertation dans un esprit qui me
semble sensiblement meilleur que celui
qui avait précédé puisque nous voyons
les syndicats de magistrats à revenir
autour de la table c'est une excellente
chose ça pro finalement que on a des
marches portent ses fruits que j'ai vu
avec satisfaction les propos du
président du Conseil National des
Barreaux très positifs sur la manière
dont les choses s'abordent je vois
monsieur le Président qui commence à me
faire des regards haineux donc je vais
essayer de terminer rapidement et vous
avez vous-même et vous avez peut-être le
mot
terminé cher collègue voilà je termine
et vous avez vous-même évoqué les
évolutions absolument colossales
budgétaire une autre par exemple cette
année c'est 380 auditeurs de justice à
l'école administrature quand je l'ai
fait c'était 85 on peut mesurer on peut
mesurer la différence et en fait la
question centrale c'était quelle feuille
de route quelle suite donnez-vous à tous
ces aspects là vous y avez largement
répondu nous serons à vos côtés nous
serons à vos côtés sur ces multiples
débats sur ces multiples chantiers vous
l'avez dit les chantiers poussent et
nous saurons prendre notre
responsabilité on la matière bon bien
vous avez vu que nos collègues ont pris
quelques libertés donc ce sera 3 minutes
pour les premiers intervenants de chaque
groupe naturellement parce que les
règles sont les mêmes pour tout le monde
je rappelle que c'est parfois dépend de
vos collègues puisque lorsque ces 3
minutes pour le premier intervenant ça
peut être une minute pour le dernier
intervenant c'est aussi la règle
la parole est à Madame Pascal borde pour
le rassemblement national
j'ai noté que vous aviez pris la parole
pendant à peu près 30 minutes mais que
pas un mot n'a été dit en ce qui
concerne les victimes c'est dire la
place qu'on accorde aujourd'hui à la
victime dans le procès pénal je referme
la parenthèse
monsieur le ministreiel feu à la maison
justice les membres du comité des états
généraux de la Justice ont unanimement
et c'est assez rare pour être souligné
partagez le constat de la crise majeure
de l'institution judiciaire et ils ont
mis en exergue l'état de délabrement
avancé c'est l'expression utilisée état
de délabrement avancé dans lequel
institution judiciaire se trouve
aujourd'hui délabrement qui amènent
certains à parler de clochardisation de
la justice je répète clochardisation de
la justice et dire l'état de décrépitude
dans lequel le système se trouve la
justice ne parvient plus à remplir son
rôle qui est pourtant si nécessaire à la
cohésion de notre société et ce par
manque criant de moyens humains mais ça
ne suffit pas il y a également un manque
criant de moyens matériels et
budgétaires la France compte un effet
quinze magistrats pour 100.000 habitants
soit moitié humain moitié moins que la
moyenne européenne
à cette pénurie d'effectif s'ajoute une
pénurie de matériel un outil
informatique totalement obsolète des
audiences nocturnes des milliers de
dossiers en souffrance dans les
tribunaux ce que vous avez appelé les
stocks bref les acteurs du monde
judiciaire sont découragés épuisés et
font face à une vague de submersion
conséquence de cela entre autres la
collégialité qui est quand même le gage
d'une justice de qualité a depuis
longtemps je dirais même très longtemps
laissez la place à des audiences à juge
uniques ce qui est totalement
inacceptable dans la plupart des
dossiers en matière pénale les audiences
de comparution immédiates ne permettent
pas de rendre une justice de qualité
puisqu'effectivement tout est traité
très rapidement les magistrats n'ont pas
vraiment le temps de prendre de prendre
connaissance du dossier pas plus que les
avocats et tout ceci contribue à
multiplier le prononcé de courte peine
d'arbres prisonniers de voir de mesures
alternatives à la prison et ce d'autant
que dans le même temps il n'y a pas
suffisamment de place de prison
situation qui amène les japes à se
conduire en gestionnaire de stocks de
place de prison ce qu'il a aussi est
totalement inabicible ce sont des
magistrats et pas des gestionnaires de
stock cette situation est donc
totalement inadmissible et elle génère
une incompréhension galopante des
justiciables vous en avez parlé et un
découragement totalement abyssal des
professionnels de justice découragement
accrus par la vague de réforme en tout
genre qui se sont succédés notamment en
matière procédurale pour un résultat qui
n'est pas loin sans faux au rendez-vous
monsieur le ministre allez-vous laisser
les justiciables et l'ensemble des
acteurs du monde judiciaire dans cette
situation de désespérance totale
allez-vous laisser la justice éloigner
encore plus chaque jour justiciable ou
bien allez-vous enfin véritablement vous
saisir de cette crise
madame Raquel Garrido pour le groupe la
France insoumise
monsieur le Président Sacha olier
monsieur le garde des sceaux il n'y a
qu'à lire quelques titres et
interstitres du rapport du Comité des
états généraux de la justice pour
constater l'état de délabrement notre
institution judiciaire morceau choisi la
justice au bord de la rupture la justice
ne parvient plus à protéger les plus
fragiles des acteurs en souffrance un
sous investissement chronique c'est très
éloquent alors face à ce constat vous
nous parlez du budget 2023 dont vous
êtes très fier et je vous le dis
monsieur le gardeesseau ne vous
gargarisez pas d'ailleurs vous avez vous
savez tellement que c'est insuffisant
que vous venez nous annoncer aujourd'hui
primeur de la commission une loi de
programmation alors parlons-en vu que
c'est l'objet du jour
à quoi pouvons-nous comparer cette loi
de programmation et bien moi je la
compare à celle du ministère de
l'Intérieur puisque c'est la seule que
j'ai sous la main à titre de comparaison
c'est combien celle du ministère
d'intérieur 15 milliards et vous vous
avez obtenu combien
pour la justice comparons à 15 milliards
sur le fond également on peut comparer à
la locmin puisque la locmin propose
d'éliminer des juges pour la gestion de
nouveaux de centaines de nouveaux délits
par la création d'amendes forfaitaire
délictuelle vous êtes pour ça monsieur
le gardeesseau éliminer les juges
éliminer le contact humain
éliminer le contradictoire
rendre automatique des peines vous êtes
pour ça cette défiance vis-à-vis du juge
alors
j'entends que vous dites que il faut
absolument éviter la justice privée et
incidemment je vois bien que vous
essayez de surfer sur une polémique du
jour à ce propos en pointant du doigt
les parties qui ont mis en place des
cellules de veille sur les cellules sur
les violences sexuelles sexistes et
sexuelles et je vous le dis attention ne
vous mêlez pas de ce qui vous regarde
pas ce qui vous regarde ce qui vous
regarde c'est le bon fonctionnement de
la justice et si les femmes aujourd'hui
craignent d'entrer dans les
commissariats si les femmes aujourd'hui
ont si peu confiance dans le système
judiciaire pour être protégé c'est ça
votre responsabilité pour le reste vous
êtes aussi pardonnez-moi de vous le dire
monsieur le garder sceaux assez
hypocrite puisque la justice privée vous
n'êtes pas vous n'êtes pas contre dans
la mesure où vous n'êtes pas contre par
exemple l'arbitrage l'arbitrage
commercial est une justice privée contre
laquelle vous n'avez jamais rien dit la
déontologie vous n'avez rien contre
j'imagine votre profession antérieure
est la mienne est régie par des
déontologies une biologie des décentions
ça ne pose problème à personne donc
faites ce que vous vous avez à faire je
termine en relevant que au Sénat un
sénateur a annoncé ce jour que ces
jours-ci qu'il y aurait apparemment dans
dans les projets une loi sur la justice
au quotidien est-ce qu'on peut en savoir
davantage ouais il faut toujours
apprendre ce que vous ferez par la
presse merci alors je vous rappelle et
on a établi cette règle la semaine
dernière que quand vous adressez de
façon un peu virulente au ministre il
peut répondre de la même manière sans
que ça vous émeuble d'accord c'est pour
c'est pour l'avenir monsieur xioti pour
le groupe les républicain
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
monsieur le ministre vous nous avez
décrit un monde merveilleux où tout
serait parfait je crois hélas
malheureusement que nos concitoyens
comme les magistrats vivent au quotidien
à une situation très différente vous
nous avez annoncé une hausse des moyens
mais cette hausse des moyens elle est
très largement en retard sur
l'augmentation de la violence qui
malheureusement frappe notre société
ceci étant dit je veux vous poser
quelques questions précises sur des
points qui figurent dans votre propos
d'abord sur la délinquance des mineurs
il y a deux ans quand vous nous avez
vous avez été auditionné pour la
première fois devant la commission des
lois vous avez parlé de reprendre une de
mes propositions qui concernaient
l'encadrement le procès-verbal en fera
foi de type militaire
pour les délinquants mineurs il y a une
loi qui existe dans la matière c'est le
service citoyen pour les mineurs
délinquants où est-elle
canet-elle de son application et des
moyens qui avaient été bloqués par votre
prédécesseur lointain sur cette loi sur
les prisons vous avez dit c'est un peu
étonnant que les places de prison
poussaient comme des champignons je
crains que ce soit des champignons
hallucinogènes parce que pour le moment
nous ne les se vend que très peu et je
voudrais vous interroger sur l'évolution
du projet de nouvelles prisons dans le
département des Alpes-Maritimes qui est
bloquée depuis des années le préfet m'a
dit que vous aviez une solution
j'aimerais bien la connaître à ce stade
parce que pour l'instant l'état de la
maison d'arrêt de Nice est à dans un
état dans un état de vétusté indigne
sans caméra avec des conditions de
sécurité qui sont indignes d'un
établissement
pénitentiaire ensuite je voudrais vous
interroger sur un point qui relève plus
de la Loomi mais naturellement vous avez
un avis à nous donner sur les amendes
forfaitaire délictuelles qui selon la
vie du Conseil d'État rendu le 7
septembre et qui reprenait celui du 12
mars va supprimer
3400 délits qui ne pourront pas être
poursuivies j'ai rien contre sur
l'amende forfaitaire des rituel elle
peut être un élément d'accélération de
la justice mais quelle est la position
du garde des sur cette question et
dernière question le ministre de
l'Intérieur qui se soucie beaucoup de la
justice et il a raison puisque c'est
naturellement un des points bloquants
pour l'amélioration des conditions de
sécurité à évoquer la possibilité du
retour à la double peine pour les
détenus les condamnés plutôt d'origine
étrangère quel est votre position sur
cette proposition du ministre de
l'Intérieur sur la double peine je vous
remercie monsieur le mix merci Monsieur
Philippe laton pour le groupe démocrate
merci monsieur le Président le groupe
démocrate est résolument favorable et
engagé à tout ce qui permettra de
numériser l'État au profit de nos
concitoyens tant pour simplifier les
démarches que pour permettre de limiter
les coûts inutiles c'est la feuille de
route de notre ministre du numérique et
des télécommunications Jean-Noël
Barrault et du gouvernement dans son
ensemble mais question vont donc
monsieur le ministre être retourné vers
ce sujet je voudrais d'abord en
préambule vous remonter un cas précis
celui du site d'information financière
pas peur ce site propose en accès libre
et gratuit les éléments financiers des
entreprises
or alors que certaines entreprises
souhaitent la plus grande
confidentialité de ces éléments pas peur
se reconstitue les comptes déposés
confidentiellement au RCS ma première
question ponctuelle est la suivante le
ministère de la Justice entend-il se
saisir sur le respect de ces textes par
des opérateurs privés qui s'alimentent
auprès du RNC ouvert en Open Data par
l'INPI
ma seconde question est plus large les
usages du numérique font dorénavant
partie de la vie quotidienne de nos
concitoyens et on voit bien que le
secteur privé est talent pour permettre
de les faciliter
en matière de justice ces usages et on
le voit bien avec pas peur sont attendus
et pris en charge par le secteur privé
cela notamment du fait d'une faible
numérisation de la justice et de projets
informatiques abandonnés depuis
plusieurs années et encore récemment la
place du ministère est dans ce domaine
de manière assez consensuellement perçue
comme assez faible et c'est un
euphémisme
se développe également dans d'autres
pays sous l'égide de leur ministère
respectifs des logiciels d'aide à la
décision autrement dit des logiciels des
logiciels de justice prédictive
quelle est Monsieur le Ministre de
manière très concrète la feuille de
route numérique du ministère de la
Justice dans les prochains mois au
profil de nos concitoyens
enfin c'est une inquiétude depuis de
longs mois comment allez-vous
fonctionner à compter du 1er janvier
prochain pour que les procureurs
puissent continuer à effectuer les
réquisitions de Fadette et de
métadonnées de connexion dans les
enquêtes qu'il conduisent la censure
constitutionnelle et les décisions de la
CGE sont aujourd'hui sans réponse
législatives pourtant nécessaire je vous
remercie
merci madame Cécile Hunter pour le
groupe socialiste
merci monsieur le Président cela a été
dit déjà parlé précédent orateurs ou
oratrices les états généraux de la
justice qui se sont déroulées donc de
fin 2021 avril 2022 dresse un constat à
blanc de la défaillance du service
public de la justice c'est une
interrogation que nous devons avoir
d'ailleurs sur d'autres services publics
mais nous l'avons pour celui-ci en
commission des lois et nous le savions
déjà les plus fragiles s'en sont donc
éloignés depuis longtemps il règle comme
ils peuvent leur litige civile et
finalement très souvent renonce à aller
vers la justice ce malaise est Ossus
aussi celui de l'ensemble des
professionnels auxquels nous devons
rendre hommage mais la question majeure
reste quand même la question de l'accès
à la justice dans la France du 21e
siècle avec des délais compatibles quand
même avec la vie que nous menons et ces
délais n'oublions pas le premier ressort
mais n'oublions pas non plus l'appel
parce que là aussi les appels en matière
de prud'hommes en particulier
tout à fait incroyable et alarmant alors
monsieur le ministre vous avez exprimé
et nous vous en remercions une volonté
de sortir la justice de l'ornière dans
laquelle elle se situe il y a une vraie
urgence il y a de la gravité et il y a
de l'inquiétude et je pense que vous
avez parlé de terme de co-construction
je voudrais savoir pour rebondir sur ce
terme comment vous envisagez cette coupe
construction avec le Parlement
s'agissant d'une réforme de long terme
parce que nous ne ferons rien de
véritablement
flagrant en un an
le rapport du comité présidé par
Jean-Marc Sauvé au travers de ces 217
pages a rappelé que cette réforme de la
justice doit se faire en
retravaillant la question d'un système
de réforme le caractère la réforme
systémique de la justice elle s'impose
et nous avons année après année
examiner des lois voter des lois et je
ne suis pas sûr que le résultat soit
probant il ne l'est pas comment
allez-vous faire à travers les réformes
que vous vous proposez garantir le
caractère efficace des mesures que vous
prenez et des avancées que nous avons
que nous devons absolument réaliser dans
le cadre de cette réforme et de ce plan
de programmation que vous nous annoncez
j'ai encore quelques minutes donc je
vais
rajouter que l'investissement c'est très
bien l'investissement régulier c'est
important sans doute faut-il aller
beaucoup plus loin mais l'investissement
tout autant il nous faut une vision et
un pilotage et sur ce point-là nous
n'avons pas de garantie d'une vision et
d'un pilotage et sur ce point j'aimerais
également savoir comment vous envisagez
de porter ses réformes merci Monsieur
Philippe Pradal pour le groupe horizon
c'est le président
monsieur le président monsieur le garde
des sceaux chers collègues je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre de votre
présence aujourd'hui en commission des
lois et pour la clarté sans surprise de
vos propos le groupe Horizon est
absolument en ligne avec les priorités
que vous déclinez dans votre circulaire
de politique pénale générale du 20
septembre dernier je pense
particulièrement à votre incitation pour
les membres du parquet à prendre attache
et renforcer les échanges avec les élus
mère et président des conseils
départementaux en particulier je
souhaitais dire un mot d'un sujet qui me
tient à coeur les victimes de squat un
arrêt de la Cour de cassation du 15
septembre 2022 interroge la Corée
développe qu'il est indispensable
d'entretenir un local même s'il est
occupé par une personne sans aucun droit
en cas d'accident la responsabilité du
propriétaire est engagée une personne
dans le local est squattée ainsi devra
donc indemniser son squatteur blessé
suite à un défaut d'entretien du local
je souhaite vivement que l'on puisse
discuter de ce thème dans le cadre d'une
loi durant cette législature le droit de
propriété ne peut pas être
systématiquement supplanté par tous les
autres droits subjectifs que nous
connaissons
cela étant dit souhaiter vous interroger
rapidement sur trois points depuis le 30
mars 2021 l'équipement suivi justice
expérimente une solution numérique qui
envoie par SMS une confirmation des
convocations aux personnes sous ma
justice et programme automatiquement un
rappel par SMS 48 heures avant la
convocation
quel bilan pour cet outil de lutte
contre l'absentéisme au rendez-vous
comptez-vous élargir les modalités de
son utilisation notamment la période
préalable au jugement seconde question
depuis le 1er juillet 2022 il est
possible de changer son nom de famille
par simple déclaration à l'état civil
c'est toute récente réformes fait-elle
l'objet d'une évaluation par vos
services et d'un bilan avez-vous un
retour notamment sur le nombre de
personnes qui se sont saisies de cette
nouvelle possibilité
enfin comme la suite à l'intervention de
notre collègue fitness ski dans le cadre
d'une question d'actualité et de notre
collègue la tombe à l'instant nous
souhaiterions savoir quels sont les
évolutions législatives envisagées à ce
stade afin de faire face à la nouvelle
situation créée par plusieurs arrêts de
la Cour de cassation du 22 juillet 2002
concernant la conservation des données
de connexion et l'accès de celle-ci dans
le cadre des procédures pénales je vous
remercie merci Monsieur jérémyordanov
pour le groupe écologiste
ça fonctionne oui merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre bonjour
chers collègues la justice est au bord
de la rupture ce sont les termes du
comité des états généraux de la justice
présidé par Jean-Marc Sauvet dans le
rapport accablant a été rendu le 8
juillet dernier vous l'avez mentionné
le personnel n'a plus les moyens de
rendre une justice de qualité les cadans
sont infernales la perte de sens est là
nous en sommes à ce qu'il convient
d'appeler de l'abattage de jugement
monsieur le ministre cela n'est pas
rendre la justice se surmenage a pour
cause certaines le manque de magistrats
et de greffiers la justice française est
sous-financée j'ai entendu vos annonces
mais la comparaison avec nos voisins
européens vous le savez reste cruel
le justiciable et la victime collatérale
de ce manque de moyens le recours à la
justice est un parcours du combattant
les délais de jugement sont
désespérément longs et ce sont les plus
faibles qui en souffrent les premiers
quant aux prisons madame Simoneau contre
le général des lieux de privation de
liberté vous le rappelle dans une
récente Tribune le vrai scandale n'est
pas les activités récréatives mais bien
la surpopulation carcérale et
l'insalubrité 700 personnes dorment
chaque nuit sur des matelas à même le
sol côtoyant parfois les rats les
punaises ou les cafards
la France a été condamnée par la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme pour
ses traitements inhumains et dégradants
cela doit cesser monsieur le ministre la
confiance de nos concitoyens dans
l'institution judiciaire est un enjeu
fondamental je le dis avec d'autant plus
de gravité qu'il faut aujourd'hui
défendre le droit et l'état de droit
face à la montée du populisme
la crise n'est pas une fatalité les
solutions sont sur la table
je salue les efforts annoncés sur les
effectifs de magistrats et de greffiers
dans l'attente bien évidemment que cela
se traduise sur le terrain
des moyens matériels vous avez trop peu
parlé de cela j'aimerais vous entendre
un petit peu plus longuement là dessus
allez vous ensuite revaloriser le statut
et la formation des greffiers allez vous
renforcer les services d'insertion et de
probation
comptez-vous réduire les courtes peines
allez-vous développer les pins
alternatives et revaloriser le milieu
ouvert
et de manière générale au-delà du plan
immobilier et que vous annoncez que
comptez-vous faire pour mettre fin à la
surpopulation carcérale je vous remercie
merci Madame Emeline kabadie en visio
pour le groupe gauche-démocrate et
républicaine
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
garde des sceaux j'ai deux questions à
vous poser la première concerne les
moyens à louer à la justice et en
particulier dans les territoires
d'outre-mer vous annoncez une hausse des
budgets effectivement c'est un bon début
mais malheureusement cette hausse est
trop faible au regard des besoins qui
sont ceux exposés dans tous les
territoires et particulièrement dans ce
d'outre-mer le ministère dont vous avez
la charge est complètement exemples et
vous avez reconnu vous-même des moyens
financiers et humains
énormes au regard des besoins
et je dois vous dire que cela ne suffit
pas cela ne suffit pas à la Réunion où
je suis élue mais où je suis également
avocate on compte un magistrat du
parquet pour 3000 dossiers leur charge
de travail est oui 8 fois supérieur à
celle des collègues qui exercent sur le
territoire hexagonal ce manque de moyens
se combine avec une
très important des violences
intrafamidales on compte plus 20% entre
2019 et 2021 la situation carcérale
n'est malheureusement pas en reste
dont la presse locale ce matin les
Réunionnais ont découvert un détenu qui
fait le buzz sur les réseaux sociaux en
ce filmant donc avec des vidéos en
direct de sa cellule ou dans la cour de
l'établissement
on manque de place cruellement en milieu
pénitentiaire les majeurs positifs sont
placés positifs au covid sont placés
dans les mêmes quartiers que les mineurs
par exemple et pour ce qui concerne les
avocats la dotation annuelle au titre de
l'aide juridictionnelle était épuisée
dès le mois de juin de cette année donc
des exemples de dysfonctionnement comme
cela j'en ai malheureusement à l'appel
et y compris dans le domaine de la
justice civile où les moyens manquent
également cruellement donc les
professionnels de la justice du monde
bien n'attendent pas une énième un
énième décret Magendie on vous demande
pas de créer des caducités des
irrecevabilité ou des nudités à l'appel
pour éviter d'avoir à rendre la justice
et à modifier artificiellement les
résultats on attend des solutions
immédiates et concrètes monsieur le
garde des sceaux quels sont ces
mesures immédiates que vous comptez
prendre j'aurai une deuxième question
qui celle là me tient à cœur et qui
concerne spécifiquement le département
de La Réunion et peut-être au-delà
d'autres départements d'outre-mer nous
avons à la Réunion cent mille personnes
qui souffrent d'illettrices mais qui
malheureusement ne maîtrise pas
correctement la langue française et ce
parlent uniquement la langue créole pour
ces personnes là il n'existent pas
d'experts auprès de la Cour d'appel en
langue créole elles doivent donc faire
face à des magistrats qui c'est qui ce
qui parle uniquement le français ne les
comprennent pas et dont elle ne peut pas
se faire comprendre voilà donc est-ce
qu'il serait possible d'avoir des
experts auprès de la Cour d'appel en
langue créole beaucoup de personnes
monsieur sansurgers
et territoire
oui merci je vous ministre chacun
partage les constats la justice ne
répond pas aux attentes de nos
concitoyens les causes en sont multiples
et partager elles sont d'abord un manque
de moyens elles sont également des faux
d'organisation vous venez monsieur le
ministre de présenter votre volonté
d'action et des grandes orientations
dont je dois dire que je les partage et
les soutiens nous avons tous un devoir
commun quel que soit nos rôles vos
gouvernements nous au Parlement de faire
des cinq années qui viennent des années
utiles pour améliorer le fonctionnement
de justice au niveau de concitoyens je
me permettrai monsieur le ministre de me
concentrer sur un point sur JS pénal la
justice fait mal et l'excent des
dysfonctionnements hélas dans notre pays
la justice pénale ne peut être efficace
que si elle est un maillon d'une chaîne
pénale qui donne toutes l'efficacité au
travail d'enquête de nos forces de
l'ordre elle ne peut être également
efficace que si elle prononce des
sanctions des sanctions qui sont
rapidement prononcées et rapidement
exécuter je me permets donc de suggérer
deux priorités la première si je peux me
permettre ce ministre de la sobriété
législative car je crois que l'essentiel
des dispositions pédales nous les avons
la seconde c'est la concentration des
moyens pour que nos concitoyens voient
bien l'application des sons de justice
monsieur mise j'avais eu démontré fort
au dixième anniversaire de l'agence qui
gère et recouvre les avoir saisis et
confisqués je pense que nous sommes
encore très loin de ce que nous pouvons
faire même si nous avons les meilleurs
chiffres encore l'année dernière en
matière de saisie de confiscation des
biens je veux redire ici combien a-t-il
important que dans tout secteurs de
notre pays un exemple de train de vie
réussie elle ne soit pas un exemple de
train de vie basé sur le trafic et là
délinquance oui nous avons besoin que
les voitures comme tous les signes
instantatoires de richesse quel que soit
les secteurs d'autres pays soit saisi
oui nous avons saisi nous avons besoin
que des personnes quand bien même elles
sont condamnées à la peine de prison ne
retrouve pas à la sortie ni à ni leurs
proches le produit de une violation des
lois avec tous les gains patrimoniaux
dont ils ont pu bénéficier merci
monsieur le ministre de votre
mobilisation en ces directions également
bien merci mes chers collègues pour ces
premières questions monsieur le ministre
vous avez la parole pour répondre à
cette première salle
réponse et Monsieur le Député Didier
Paris je voudrais dire un mot puisque on
retrouve ces préoccupations dans
beaucoup de questions sur les états
généraux et sur leur méthodologie
je pense que on réforme pas la justice
sans avoir préalablement obtenu son
consentement
justice est une vieille dame
et elle craint
elle a déjà démontré par le passé
les modifications qui peuvent intervenir
je rappelle que quand on a décidé de
créer le JLD
au combien cette création a fait l'objet
de discussions et de critiques virulente
qui aujourd'hui
oserait contester le JLD donc si je vous
dis cela c'est pour vous dire que la
méthode que j'ai choisie c'était de ne
pas intervenir dans le comité des États
généraux j'ai décidé de ne pas
appartenir à ce comité pour le laisser
travailler en toute liberté pas
davantage je n'ai mis ma pâte
dans les différents ateliers qui ont été
créés je ne voulais pas que l'on dise
qu'au fond tout cela était une sorte de
mystification et que c'était la volonté
du ministre qui allait s'exprimer dans
cette temporalité assez longue
d'ailleurs où les États généraux ont
travaillé une fois que le rapport sauvé
était rendu que les annexes ont été
rendues j'ai souhaité à ce moment-là
organiser une concertation très très
large très large je voudrais vous dire
que d'une certaine façon
on a mis en place une forme de nouvelle
gouvernance au fond j'aurais pu très
bien décider avec mon cabinet et puis
ensuite imposer sur le contrôle
naturellement strict du Parlement qui
fait son travail c'est pas ce qu'on a
choisi de faire on s'est dit que on ne
pouvait bouger les choses que si on
avait un large consensus donc j'ai
rencontré tout le monde j'ai pris
beaucoup de temps je l'ai fait en deux
étapes j'ai rencontré les syndicats qui
ont souhaité venir pas tous la première
fois puis davantage la deuxième j'ai
rencontré force de sécurité intérieure
j'ai rencontré les compatriotes certains
d'entre eux avaient évidemment fait
valoir un certain nombre de choses sur
la plateforme rencontrait bien sûr
magistrat avocat greffier directeur de
grève en fait tout le monde tout le
monde
de ces concertations qui ne sont pas
encore tout à fait fini n'a pas trop
vite il reste une semaine de travail il
y a un certain nombre de choses qui se
dégagent
parmi les lignes de force il y a
l'impérieuse nécessité de simplifier la
procédure pénale
on parlait tout à l'heure d'inflation
législatives moi je veux faire de la de
la déflation mais il faut quand même
s'agissant de la procédure pénale passer
par un texte on peut pas faire de la
déflation sans prendre un texte nouveau
ce texte on l'envisage d'ici deux années
et pour répondre à ce que disait madame
c'est si l'auteur Meyer évidemment que
le Parlement ça de près associé à
l'élaboration de ce texte de procédure
pénale en matière civile on a beaucoup
de réglementaires mais je veux associer
les parlementaires au réglementaires il
y a des lignes force qui de force qui se
dégagent les arbitrages de son pas
encore pris mais il y a la médiation
bien sûr il y a l'équipe autour du
magistrat quelque chose de tout à fait
nouveau pour permettre justement d'abord
de régler quelques-unes des questions
que poser les jeunes dans la tribune des
3000 la solitude du magistrat le sens de
sa mission mais aussi pour aller plus
vite on sait qu'un juriste assistant
avec un magistrat c'est la moitié de
temps pour rédiger une décision
et je les redis d'aucun ne veulent pas
longtemps mais on a nationalement un
déstockage massif dans les affaires
familiales le pôle social le contentieux
de la protection et la matière pénale et
ça c'est du à l'époque à la porte de ce
que l'on a appelé les sucres rapides
donc puisque vous m'avez posé la
question sur la méthodologie des États
généraux moi maintenant j'y suis
naturellement je discute on échange on a
un certain nombre de pistes vous avez vu
par exemple pour prendre un exemple le
rapport de Madame Lottin dont vous avez
dû prendre connaissance elle suggère
deux possibilités pour créer l'équipe
autour du magistrat que va-t-on choisir
moi je propose aux uns et aux autres aux
conférences au magistrat au greffier il
m'apporte une réponse
on prend en considération tout ça et ce
que l'on veut c'est présenter un projet
un plan d'action qui soit consensuel
dans ce sens que c'est une sorte de
changement dans la gouvernance je veux
pas que ça parte du haut pour irriguer
ensuite les différents services je veux
qu'on soit dans une co-construction il
me paraît très important de l'indiquer
je veux répondre ensuite et on y
reviendra si vous le voulez à Madame
bordesse on dit bord de bordel
au singulier ça me va très bien board au
singulier alors madame borde vous n'avez
pas été attentive parce que dans mon
discours contrairement à ce que vous
avez dit j'ai prononcé trois mois le
vaut 2 3 fois le mode victime je le
tiens à votre disposition ce n'est pas
grave vous avez cru de voir dire cela
je ne vous en veux pas au fond peut-être
j'étais trop long et peut-être vous
ai-je perdu dans votre attention qui me
paraissait acquise
en matière de de
d'embauche en matière de moyens je
voudrais vous dire que
vous proposiez 9000 magistrats dans ce
pays alors que nous avions déjà
largement dépassé ce chiffre
vous proposiez par ailleurs une peine de
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité qui
existait déjà voilà les deux
propositions phares que vous aviez dans
un livre que vous aviez intitulé
vous-même le livre blanc vous en aviez
choisi la couleur donc c'est dire le
sérieux des propositions que vous avez
pu faire à un moment alors on va redire
les choses voyez je veux pas parler
parce que ça sert pas à grand chose il y
a un tweet de l'Union Syndicale des
Magistrats de l'USM de ce matin qui
rappelle que c'est un triplet historique
madame la clochardisation c'est un
ministre socialiste qui avait utilisé ce
mot comme quoi les emprunts peuvent être
utiles à une époque à une époque où nous
étions loin d'avoir obtenu les budgets
que nous avons obtenus parce que je vais
vous dire on peut toujours critiquer
mais moi ce que je propose voyez dans
l'analyse de l'action qui peut être la
mienne et au fond de toute action
publique c'est de voir d'où nous venons
où nous sommes et où nous allons moi je
dis qu'il reste des choses à faire je
vous annoncer un plan d'embauche massif
je vous mets annoncer le budget 2023
mais il faut quand même vous souvenir
que nous nous avons embauché 700
magistrats ou 150 greffiers 2000
personnels supplémentaires personne
personne madame personne madame la
députée avons-nous ne l'avait fait et
l'Union Syndicale des Magistrats qui a
assisté ce matin à la présentation à
parler de triplés historique oui triplet
historique les mots ont un sens alors
vous pouvez toujours dire que vous
feriez mieux que vous feriez plus il y a
qu'à faucon faudrait j'entends bien cela
mais voyez les victimes c'est au cœur de
la politique pénale que je mène et
d'ailleurs dans le discours mais
peut-être vous êtes à ce moment-là
encore perdu j'ai décliné ce que nous
avions fait pour la mise en place
notamment du Grenelle et personne ne
peut sérieusement dire que nous n'avons
rien fait en matière de bracelet anti
rapprochement téléphone grave danger si
vous saviez le nombre d'infractions qui
ont été évitées et de violence qui ont
été évitées en matière d'ordonnance
d'éloignement en matière de de
largement des victimes des auteurs parce
que les auteurs il faut aussi les
héberger parce que la période critique
c'est quand ils pensent que leurs femmes
à eux avec un singulier possessif et
dans leur maison à eux et c'est là où il
faut qu'on intervienne et que
naturellement on trouve un certain
nombre de solutions bon voilà j'ai
entendu votre question c'était davantage
une critique assez peu constructive
qu'une question mais je pense cependant
y avoir répandu monsieur le député
sciotti on a
au fond chaque fois qu'on a une bonne
idée c'est la vôtre
ça peut arriver
bon votre vision de l'armée et de la
jeunesse n'est pas la mienne
nous ce que nous avons mis en place dans
l'expérimentation je vais vous le dire
ce sont des délinquants
qui sont enfermés dans des centres
éducatifs fermés c'est déjà une
délinquance de de haut niveau dans le
spectre
ces jeunes à un moment
on les envoie en stage avec des
militaires
là-dessus je pense qu'on sera d'accord
les militaires peuvent leur apporter
sens de la solidarité du dépassement de
soi
on se lève le matin on est cadré et
encadré et c'est un encadrement à la
fois ferme et bienveillant
il y a des gamins qui peuvent pas
supporter ça donc c'est pas la peine de
les envoyer là-bas sinon on aurait la
solution magique je la laisse à d'autres
qui consistera à mettre les gamins dans
un bus et à les envoyer dans une caserne
c'est pas comme ça que ça marche il faut
préalablement l'expertise de la PJJ mais
cette expérience elle fonctionne le
président de la République dans sa
campagne a promis que l'on
intensifierait cette expérience c'est
que d'expérience ça deviendrait une
réalité j'y travaille avec Sébastien
Lecornu on est assez loin de ce que vous
préconisiez comme vous le savez par
ailleurs c'est une deuxième question que
vous me posez le Conseil d'État a émis
un avis réservé sur l'extension des AFD
bon on va prendre évidemment en compte
son avis ça va de soi et nous ferons les
choses dans le respect de l'État de
droit et des préconisations du Conseil
d'État sur la prison
si j'osais une familiarité je dirais que
vous êtes gonflé quand même mais je
n'ose pas cette familiarité j'ai trop de
respect pour l'homme et pour le
parlementaire que vous êtes mais enfin
tout de même n'est ce pas vous qui vous
êtes opposés à la construction de la
prison de Saint-Laurent-du-Var ah
non non non ben oui oui oui parce que
vous aviez aussi la possibilité de me
proposer un certain nombre de choses et
pardonnez-moi
écoutez
moi je sais qu'elles ont été mes
interlocuteurs je travaille encore la
semaine dernière avec Christian Estrosi
pour trouver un terrain vous me dites
attendez attendez deux minutes écoutez
non écoutez bien écoutez bien je vous
donne un autre exemple parce qu'il y a
celui-là mais il y en a un autre
vous êtes sur un plateau de télévision
libre à vous et vous dites après ces
événements terribles où on voit une
vieille dame rouée de coups vous dites
faut absolument construire les selfs oui
pourquoi vous ne me proposez pas un
terrain pour les construire je demande
que ça ah oui
à qui
non monsieur monsieur
je sais que je suis Madame tobira empire
je sais que je vais remplir mais
pardonnez-moi
bien sûr
non non non
monsieur Ciotti non non faut pas
exagérer mais vous allez pas vous en
tirer comme ça parce que moi vous ne
m'avez jamais fait une proposition et
vous êtes et vous êtes comme un certain
nombre laissez-moi terminer je ne vous
ai pas interrompu je souhaite que vous
ne m'interrompiez pas bon ce que vous
dites n'est pas juste vous ne m'avez pas
fait l'ombre de longe d'une proposition
alors jouer le sécuritaire c'est bien
mais au fond j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
dire pardon je regarde trop la
télévision que c'est un peu comme les
mcken c'est ce qu'on parle le plus qu'on
mange le moins parce que j'attends
toujours que vous me fassiez une
proposition j'ai dit j'ai dit de façon
claire nette que j'étais prêt pour un
chef que j'étais prêt pour un
établissement pénitentiaire vous avez
été incapable demander aussi votre avis
monsieur Lisnard de me trouver un
terrain à Cannes pour construire un cèpe
on y va tout de suite non c'est pas de
la démagogie monsieur cioti c'est vous
c'est vous c'est vous non
s'il vous plaît
j'ai donné les règles tout à l'heure
vous posez des questions à Monsieur le
Ministre dans la tonalité qui vous
convient et je vous réponds dans la
tonalité qui me convient exactement non
non non non non
il y a des collègues en nombre qui
souhaitent poser des questions après
vous ça n'est pas juste ce que vous
dites ça n'est pas juste ce que vous
dites parce que les terrains
n'appartiennent pas au ministère de la
Justice et si c'était le cas monsieur
Ciotti et
je voudrais terminer mon propos et puis
chacun appréciera je pense qu'ici on a
affaire évidemment exclusivement à des
députés qui savent très bien que ces
terrains sur lesquels on construit des
établissements pénitentiaires
n'appartiennent pas au ministère de la
Justice je vais vous dire d'ailleurs
c'est là où j'ai passé le plus d'heures
depuis que je suis ministre c'est pour
essayer de convaincre dans chaque
commune dans chaque circonscription et
je vais vous dire la prison c'est
toujours pour la circo d'à côté souvent
ou la commune d'à côté sauf évidemment
saut est-ce que est-ce que je peux
terminer Julien Julien sauf ceux sauf
ceux qui ont au fond
appréhender la nécessité de construire
ces établissements et qui ne sont pas
dans la critique nihiliste et qui me
disent monsieur le ministre ben j'ai
moyen un terrain envoyer vos services
pour expertiser cela voilà oui non non
vous n'avez rien fait du tout et à
Grasse ça ne correspondait pas à la
réalité puisque il nous fallait ah vous
voulez avoir raison mais vous avez
tortue vous vouliez nous nous non je
vous permets pas de dire ça la maison
d'arrêt c'est pas c'est pas la maison
d'arrêt un établissement pénitentiaire
est-ce que je peux terminer une phrase
c'est pas où on décide de l'implanter à
grâce il n'y en avait pas besoin ce
qu'il fallait c'est un établissement
pénitentiaire proche de Nice pour une
raison simple c'est qu'il y a un TGI à
Nice et qu'il y a une prison à Nice et
que pour des raisons qui sont des
critères établis notamment par la pige
grâce ne collez pas et je vous l'ai dit
à de nombreuses reprises ne venez pas
sur ce terrain il y a qu'à faucon c'est
facile maintenant je vais vous parler du
plan que nous avons mis en place parce
que champignons hallucinogènes je crois
pas alors c'est drôle ça fait le buzz
vous ferez la dépêche AFP mais je vais
quand même vous dire 2022 4
établissements livrés Nouvelle-Calédonie
quand Montpellier le mont Coulaines 23
livraison de 10 établissements
pénitentiaires pour environ 2000 places
et moi cet été j'ai fait les chantiers
oui j'ai mis mon casque je suis allé
voir je pousse les choses parce que je
veux que ça sorte de terre cette
structure d'accompagnement en 2023
Avignon Valence mot Oni et 300 trop
pénitentiaires donc quand et quand La
Vaux
615 millions pour l'immobilier
pour l'administration pour l'immobilier
propriétaire d'administration
pénitentiaire etc etc etc prison
expérimentale programmé insert et je
vous invite vous voyez comme ça on va se
réconcilier la prochaine visite en
prison vous venez avec moi et vous
verrez que j'ai pas fumé des champignons
hallucinogènes quelle sorte de terre et
qu'elles seront prêtes et que nous
saurons au rendez-vous des promesses
présidentielles voilà dans les Ardennes
ne craignez rien nous allons construire
l'insert de Toul monsieur barman
on en vient le passé 5 minutes sur Nice
donc je pense que on peut passer à la
suite je vais je vais exproprier votre
permanence pour y construire un
établissement pénitentiaire enfin c'est
pas sérieux le ministère de la Justice
n'est pas propriétaire des terrains
vous ne m'avez rien proposé monsieur
cioti que tout le monde le sache que
tout le monde le sache je vous ai dit et
je suis encore en train de travailler
avec Monsieur Estrosi sur la recherche
d'un terrain rien n'est plus complexe
que cela voilà vous êtes des fossés et
aujourd'hui vous faites comme un certain
nombre d'autres vous faites le le la
critique nihiliste vous n'avez rien
apporté voilà alors
madame madame la députée Garrido
manque de moyens relevé par les
ogj et par le rapport sauvé oui
absolument je voudrais vous dire
d'ailleurs que dans la tempe dans la
temporalité et quelque chose qu'il faut
absolument relever c'est que le rapport
sauvé n'a pas pu prendre en compte
l'apport des embauches que nous avions
faites
les contractuels et le rapport s'arrête
à un moment ou chronologiquement c'est
jeunes gens j'ai souvent des jeunes
il s'arrête avant que ces jeunes gens
soient arrivés en juridiction c'est à
dire que le rapport sauvé ne mentionne
pas le déstockage massif dont j'ai parlé
tout à l'heure bon
ensuite bon pardon justice privé ça me
regarde quand même un tout petit peu
enfin j'ai la faiblesse ou l'immodestie
selon vous de le penser je suis garde
des sceaux il y a des choses qui me
chagrine un peu je crois moi qu'il faut
respecter un certain nombre de principes
le contradictoire
et un vrai contradictoire la présomption
d'innocence
la parole des victimes qu'il faut mieux
prendre en compte et de ce point de vue
d'ailleurs les forces de sécurité
intérieure ont été mieux formés les
magistrats suivent une formation
continue à l'École nationale de la
magistrature bon voilà ce que je peux
vous dire sur ces quelques questions
j'ajoute qu'on le veuille ou non
que ce triptyque que je proposais tout à
l'heure d'où nous venons en 2017 il y
avait pas de wifi dans les tribunaux
il n'y avait pas d'ordinateur
ultra-portable distribué
je vais pas reprendre le chiffre de
magistrat que nous avons embauché de
greffiers que nous avons embauché trois
fois une augmentation de 8% cette
historique ça n'a jamais été fait jamais
vous pouvez regarder regarder tous les
budgets ça n'existe pas maintenant il y
a deux choses qu'il faut dire
la justice manque de moyens et il est
impératif que la justice dispose des
moyens dont elle a besoin pour mieux
fonctionner mais ça n'est pas suffisant
il y a un certain nombre de réformes
structurelles
aussi villes par exemple tout ça
n'absence que si nous réduisons les
délais que si nous rendons la justice
plus proche la proximité c'est pas rien
c'est ré-ouvrir des tribunaux qui
avaient été fermés par exemple c'est
également intensifié les points justice
ou nos
compatriotes les plus démunis les plus
défavorisés vont chercher les premiers
conseils c'est un lieu où les premiers
conseils sont donnés de façon
confidentielle et gratuite voilà un
certain nombre de choses et on va être
dans le continuum de cette justice de
proximité
lui apporter davantage de moyens les
syndicats l'USM en tous les cas à
souligné ce matin mais les autres
syndicats également pas forcément de
magistrats mais pénitentiaire également
ont salué que il y avait des avancées
qui sont des avancées historiques c'est
la réalité on peut tricher avec les mots
on peut dire que
blanc et noir et que noir et blanc mais
avec les chiffres on peut pas tricher de
ce point de vue on est tenu de
reconnaître si on est objectif et je
sais que vous l'êtes mais que la justice
n'a jamais budgétairement été aussi bien
doté que ces dernières années voilà à la
fois depuis que je suis garde des sceaux
mais également depuis qu'Emmanuel Macron
a été élu président de la République
c'est une augmentation de 40%
de 40% la loi de programmation elle est
indispensable parce qu'elle va inscrire
dans la pérennité mais attendez il y
aura
10 000 embauches
1500 magistrats 1500 greffiers d'autres
personnels mais il faut affiner cela à
nez parce que par exemple sur le
personnel pénitentiel ça va se faire en
fonction de l'évolution de ces
établissements qui sortent de terre et
il faut adapter tout cela de la façon la
plus fine on ne peut pas aujourd'hui
dans le budget 2023 prévoit tout ce qui
se fera d'ici 2027 mais les engagements
sont pris je vous communiquerai on a une
on aura une un échange très approfondie
sur ces questions budgétaires et
rassurez-vous madame la députée Garrido
j'ai l'immodestie de penser que je vais
pouvoir vous rassurer pleinement
bon déjà déjà déjà c'est un sourire qui
me permet de dire que je suis peut-être
pas complètement trompé oui bon voilà on
va y arriver on va y arriver bien
monsieur le député Philippe Platon alors
sur
sur la FD sur la FD ecoutez bien elle a
montré elle a montré alors celui-là il y
a des je vais vous répondre elle a
montré son efficacité les parquets
l'utilisent largement les procureurs les
forces de sécurité intérieure ils
demandent à ce que l'on déj judiciarise
ouais
donc il y a les limites à la fois que
nous impose le Conseil d'État et il faut
également être pragmatique et utiliser
l'AFD chaque fois que c'est possible il
y a un certain nombre dans les
simplifications d'un procédure pénale ce
que l'on a vu ce que l'on envisage mais
les arbitrages ne sont pas terminés
c'est de faire en sorte qu'un certain
nombre de choses qui sont aujourd'hui
constitutives d'infraction ne le choix
plus je pense par exemple aux injures
je pense par exemple à la dualité mais
sont des choses qui ne sont pas
arbitrées mais qui ont été exprimés dans
les états généraux je vous en fait part
est-ce qu'il est normal que
en matière routière il y a à la fois une
sanction administrative et une chanson
une sanction judiciaire est-ce qu'on ne
peut pas simplifier les choses
on peut réfléchir à ça et on peut
réfléchir à ça mais alors sans aucun
dogmatisme parce que le but c'est une
fois encore de dég judiciariser ça veut
dire
gagner du temps de magistrats pour une
justice plus rapide mais plus
qualitative parce que avec ce temps de
magistrats voyez je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure les justiciables il se plaignent
parfois de ne pas assez boire leur juge
c'est tous ces équilibres qu'il faut
retrouver et vous verrez quand je
présenterai les États généraux dans peu
de temps vous verrez qu'il y a un
certain nombre de solutions qui sont
excellentes et je vais vous dire autre
chose
j'ai tenu à mettre tout le monde autour
de la table pour dégager quelque chose
de consensuel pour ne pas qu'on dise ah
mais c'est le garde des sceaux pour pas
qu'il y ait de d'opposition politicienne
stérile on a tous été dans le même sens
quand je suis avec les conférences de
les conférences chef de cours chef de
juridiction avec les greffiers avec les
avocats on essaie de co-construire
quelque chose en matière civile par
exemple on a tous fait le constat qu'il
fallait modifier le décret majindique
qu'il fallait rendre les choses plus
fluides parce que sa complexifie les
choses parce que c'est le justiciable
qui s'entend dire que l'affaire est
renvoyée à 6 mois ou à 7 mois ce qu'il
ne peut pas comprendre vous voyez il y a
peu de place pour de la petite Paul de
la petite peloche là c'est quelque chose
qui doit nous unir pour permettre pour
permettre à fluidifier les choses aller
rendre plus simple à les rendre plus
proche des justiciables et c'est un joli
but commun vous voyez moi je vais vous
dire j'ai eu l'habitude
de la co-construction code de justice
pénale des mineurs c'est une
co-construction ça a été voté au Sénat
ça n'est pas la majorité à laquelle à
laquelle j'appartiens
le la proposition qui avait été faite
par Madame billon ça a été porté je l'ai
porté avec enthousiasme qu'est-ce que je
peux dire d'autre le texte sur les
conditions indignes de détention c'est
le président François Noel buffet il y a
pas de place sur certains sujets pour de
la petite poloche donc c'est pour ça que
je désespère pas de vous convaincre vous
verrez il y a un certain nombre de
petites mesures pragmatiques et de
grandes mesures qui vont dans le bon
sens parce que la justice a besoin de ce
moderniser voilà moi je la veux plus
fluide plus efficace plus protectrice
c'est ça mon but et je pense que ça peut
être un but commun voilà alors Monsieur
le Député la tombe vous vous m'avez posé
beaucoup beaucoup de questions
alors sur le numérique
bon d'abord on veut si vous me permettez
cette familiarité mettre le paquet sur
le numéro parce que nous avons
conscience que nous avons beaucoup de
progrès accomplir et la Cour des comptes
qui n'a pas été tendre avec nous a dit
que nous avions fait des progrès il faut
en faire encore j'ai d'abord souhaité un
secrétaire général adjoint qui était
procureur
Amiens qui était très impliqué dans le
numérique en particulier
sur la PPN qui est exclusivement dédiée
si vous me permettez ce verbe
aujourd'hui à l'évolution du numérique
j'ai dit que nous allions augmenter les
réseaux j'ai dit également que nous
aurions un référent numérique partout et
nous allons y consacrer de l'argent
parce que nos souhaitons que évidemment
simplification fluidité rapidité de la
justice ça passe indubitablement par le
numérique alors concrètement pour 2023
les projets prioritaire du ministère
c'est poursuites de la procédure pénale
numérique
portalisa qui permet la modernisation du
casier judiciaire national et attijip
360 à 360
permet naturellement de
comment dirais-je
à 360 c'est une plateforme qui permet
d'avoir connaissance des tiges qui sont
disponibles ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux ces tiges
les avocats ont accès à la plateforme et
peuvent proposer eux-mêmes des tiges et
c'est une peine qui a fait ses preuves
c'est une vieille peine elle a fait ses
preuves et il faut lui donner du sens
d'ailleurs on constate que en dépit des
efforts que nous avons fait qui sont
très importants pour lancer relancer ce
travail d'intérêt général il est de
moins en moins prononcé dans ma
circulaire de politique générale je
demande à ce que on regarde avec
davantage d'intérêt si j'ose dire le
travail d'intérêt général parce que ça
marche et ça marche même il faut que
vous le sachiez vous le savez certains
jeunes connaissent grâce aux tiges leur
première expérience de travail
bon alors ensuite comme vous m'avez posé
un certain nombre de questions on est
allé sur
quel autre quel autre sujet monsieur le
connexion
bon vous avez pris évidemment
connaissance des différents arrêts qui
ont été rendus qui ont été rendus par la
Cour de cassation
on y travaille de très près parce que
nous avons besoin des données de
protection je suis pas ministre de
l'intérieur mais qu'il s'agisse des
forces de sécurité intérieure qui
s'agissent des magistrats du parquet des
magistrats nous savons à quel point
c'est important je crois que plus de 60%
des procédures pénales connaissent un
épilogue grâce aux données que d’action
bon nous sommes en train de travailler à
la question il n'est pas question bien
sûr que nous abandonnions ces données de
connexion
bon
jusque jusqu'à maintenant tout a été
préservé
tout est au bergerie grâce notamment au
travail en finesse tout en finesse
devrait-je dire du Conseil d'État
de nouveaux arrêts de cassation sont
intervenus nous les prenons en
considération nous y travaillons je
surveille ça monsieur le député comme le
lait sur le feu et si vous avez un
certain nombre d'idées à faire valoir
bienvenue ma porte je l'ai déjà dit et
je le redis d'ailleurs et toujours
ouvertes pour la critique nihiliste non
parce que c'est un peu lassant mais pour
la construction oui évidemment donc
bienvenue si vous souhaitez évoquer avec
moi ces questions madame Cécile ou
termeyer d'abord vous dire le plaisir
que j'ai de vous retrouver
voilà nous avons beaucoup travaillé
ensemble ce qui prouve que
certains nombre de sujets se déclinent
au-delà des clivages qui peuvent
apparaître de prime abord bon
qu'est-ce que vous me dites la
co-construction avec le Parlement c'est
pour moi essentiel je pense que vous le
savez je pense que je l'ai démontré on
va travailler en concertation étroite
avec le Parlement on va même vous
présenter tous nos textes réglementaires
parce qu'il est extrêmement important
que vous sachiez où on va et puis et
puis je le redis ce n'est pas une idée
ministérielle c'est bien sûr une idée
ministérielle moi j'ai fait valoir un
certain nombre de choses mais c'est
aussi tout ce que j'ai pu recueillir des
uns et des autres et les uns et les
autres ont dit d'ailleurs et ont
souligné avec beaucoup d'objectivité que
nous étions dans dans une façon
peut-être nouvelle de travailler et de
recueillir la sentiment des enzymes aux
autres vous savez pardonnez-moi vous
savez je pense aussi au moment où sur le
terrain législatif il faudra que j'aille
devant le Parlement moi mon intérêt
c'est de dire au parlementaire que tout
le monde est d'accord pour avancer sur
tel ou tel point et je pense que c'est
un atout supplémentaire que de dire au
Parlement voilà les magistrats sont
d'accord les forces de sécurité
intérieure sont d'accord les greffiers
sont d'accord bon ça présente les choses
d'une façon évidemment consensuelle et
ça l'est et ça permet peut-être de
faciliter les choses voilà donc c'était
mon but je pense que je suis parvenu on
a beaucoup beaucoup travaillé beaucoup
discutés et le Parlement sera associé de
très près à l'évolution des États
généraux parce que c'est notre bien
commun et les États généraux nous nous
concernent absolument tous alors
j'en viens maintenant
ah madame
Kabylie où est-elle madame
[Musique]
s'agissant d'abord de cette question de
l'interprétariat
en langue créole qui se pose
à la Réunion qui se pose dans d'autres
territoires la question aussi de Mayotte
qui pose aussi des questions
linguistiques particulières alors ça
n'est pas traité de façon spécifique si
j'ose dire mais c'est traité au travers
de la hausse des frais de justice et
nous augmentons notamment
les frais de justice pour permettre
justement
dans une territorialisation
dont les chefs de juridiction auront la
charge de régler ses difficultés parce
que ce sont des difficultés majeures il
peut pas y avoir de justiciables ayant
taxé à la justice et et d'autres étant
écartés pour les raisons que vous avez
évoquées numérique on n'oublie pas
évidemment l'outre-mer PPN est
opérationnel à la Réunion et en
Guadeloupe
l'immobilier Mayotte construction d'une
nouvelle cité judiciaire j'irai
prochainement inauguré à Koné une
nouvelle prison
un nouveau tribunal à Saint-Laurent j'y
vais dans deux jours
et puis on veut créer
une Task Force
5 ou 6 mois à bord de magistrats à
Mayotte et à Cayenne j'ai dit d'ailleurs
que
Mayotte par exemple ou Cayenne qui
connaissent des problèmes d'attractivité
devaient être considéré comme des
tremplins dans la carrière des greffiers
et des magistrats qui vont
travailler là-bas
ces mesures seront déclinées plus
précisément je suis tout à fait d'accord
là encore pour vous recevoir la
chancellerie et pour que je vous dis
très complètement le programme qui est
le nôtre en ce qui concerne l'Outre-mer
monsieur Pradal
alors
lutter d'abord contre l'absentéisme des
personnes placées sous main de justice
quand elle reçoivent des convocations du
service d'insertion de probation bon
bilan parce que c'est ça votre question
sur l'ensemble des sites déployés on
constate une baisse d'environ 40% de
rendez-vous non honorés
ça démontre l'efficacité la pertinence
de l'outil il est trop tôt pour un bilan
chiffré sur les autres sites déployés
l'outil d'envoi de SMS et déployé dans 6
départements
Hauts-de-Seine Eure-et-Loir Paris
Maine-et-Loire Rhône Gers au 15
septembre c'est 19000 SMS de rappel
envoyé à plus de 11500 personnes et un
site d'informations d'ores et déjà
accessible à tous depuis le site
justice.fr il s'agit de donner un
maximum d'informations sur la peine et
sur le déroulement d'une procédure
d'aménagement de peine la
personnalisation de ces sites par
territoire est en cours horaires
d'ouverture adresse précise des services
d'insertion voilà ce que je peux vous
dire sur
[Musique]
ces questions que vous m'avez posées
étant entendu que par anticipation
peut-être j'ai d'ores et déjà donné
quelques éléments sur les données de
connexion
monsieur monsieur
Yordanov qui est là
alors
s'agissant des revalorisations
vous connaissez les annonces que j'ai
faites s'agissant des magistrats ils
avaient pas été revalorisés depuis
ça n'est que justice le chiffre est
important c'est 1000 euros
mensuels brut en moyenne
si on le rapporte à la période de
dernière revalorisation
1996 ça fait un peu plus de 3 euros par
mois
c'était justice et deuxièmement on a
constaté bien sûr que les magistrats de
l'ordre judiciaire étaient moins payés
que les magistrats de leurs
administratif et comme en plus se poser
une question d'attractivité et qu'on
aimerait bien que quelques magistrats de
l'ordre administratif viennent dans
ces nouveaux magistrats de l'ordre
judiciaire qu'on souhaite embaucher on
s'est dit ce n'est pas idiot vous ne le
concéderez que quand un magistrat de
l'ordre administratif regarde sa fiche
de paie mais il a pas envie d'aller
gagner 1000 euros de moins en
participant à la justice judiciaire tout
cela il y a évidemment les greffiers
j'avais dit au graffier on attend un peu
je ferai les annonces je les ai
présentés ce matin alors d'abord il faut
que vous sachiez que
on a mis en oeuvre une importante
revalorisation indemnitaire qu'on va
poursuivre en 2023 6 millions en 2021 22
millions en 2022 et 10 millions 2023
on veut aller plus loin encore car les
greffiers ne disposent pas aujourd'hui
d'un déroulement de carrière en
catégorie 1 et dans le cadre des
réflexions sur le fonctionnement des
juridictions et sur la nécessité de
recentrer le magistrat sur son cœur de
projet on réfléchit à la création d'un
corps d'agent de catégorie 1 pour
assister le magistrat c'est la création
de ce qu'on appelle l'équipe autour du
magistrat je vais vous dire d'ailleurs
que ça aussi c'est une idée qui fait son
chemin et qui devrait faire et qui fait
dès à présent consensus voilà
naturellement les greffiers qu'il
souhaite et qui en ont les compétences
pourront accéder à ce corps et
pour ceux qui resteraient greffiers on
projette également une évolution de leur
statut afin de rendre ce métier qui est
un métier exigeant
plus attractif quand je reviendrai ici
pour évoquer le budget j'aurais
l'honneur monsieur le député de
détailler très précisément les mesures
que nous avons prises je dois dire que
personne n'a été oublié ni les
magistrats bien sûr ni les greffiers
bien sûr ni les agents administratifs ni
personnel pénitentiaire et il paraissait
extrêmement important que des
revalorisations soient ainsi arbitré
monsieur le député varsmann
sobriété législatives oui
oui évidemment
cette idée je la
partage évidemment tout sera frais pour
réduire la production normative bon il y
avait quelque chose d'assez drôle dans
les dans les rencontres qui ont eu lieu
à la Chancellerie c'est magistrats qui
m'a dit ouais mais enfin quand même
quand même faire un texte de plus pour
simplifier la procédure pénale si oui je
vois difficilement comment on pourrait
abroger un certain nombre de textes
législatifs sans passer par le Parlement
et donc évidemment nous avons souri
parce que c'est évidemment de
l'inflation législative pour partie mais
qui aura pour objet naturellement de
simplifier et de produire de la
désinflation législatives bien sûr
s'agissant du règlementaire un certain
nombre de choses évidemment seront
modifiés mais tout va dans le sens
évidemment d'une simplification ensuite
que puis-je vous dire l'insert
ma langue a fourché tout à l'heure il
sera
construit
et vous le direz à Monsieur Ciotti le
jour où ce bâtiment sera
prêt voilà ce que je voulais vous dire
ai-je oublié quelqu'un non je ne crois
pas